we're filming a sword fight I need a
really cool shot to end it and a lot of
filming something I've never seen before
with the camera nothing on the store oh
the bad guys head in slow-motion before
I can do that I need to figure out how
to build it and then film it let's put
it over on it for GoPro roll video
oh my god it's rolling GoPro stop
recording the idea is that we have this
like looking out the blade right thing
okay that looks pretty sweet we want to
make sure that the blade is leaving the
frame so like this about the speed
reducer this looks pretty sweet
how does it look going this way that
looks pretty cool yeah and we have a few
katanas like there's this one but this
is aluminum just useless for actually
chopping something we do have one steel
bladed sword it's very dull as you can
see Niko does have a really nice high
quality katana maybe he'll let us use it
for them I'm gonna say no can't Han
sorry okay
unfortunately this will have to be
destroyed used it's not ideal
now our issue is how do we sharpen that
this is steel what if we actually just
take a belt sander to it no it's either
battery going to this video
you
[Music]
I mean that kind of working dude if we
hit that with some smooth beautiful sir
oh this is sort us number one with the
mini watermelon madness that is
officially sharp let's go look at the
footage cooling ass reporter well looks
like it's so fast
did you see it wait that's going to be
expected if I go through frame by frame
we've now seen the watermelon and the
cut there's way too much motion blur
even though that we're recording at 120
frames per second the motion blur is so
intense we want to have as little motion
blur as possible which means we have to
have a very high shutter speed which
means we need to have a lot of light we
can go up to the roof where we actually
get more direct Sun like that should in
theory provide enough light for that the
shutter speed doesn't have to be dropped
let's go check it out see ya so for the
motion blur there's none I mean that was
a good test right there no motion blur
well I mean 100 percent chance of rain
tomorrow big this is going to be
something that we just have to play by
ear play by sight
[Music]
get the GoPro on okay ready can we wait
for that to come around them and slice
through hey right there are not two
GoPros on the stores and we're going to
get both angles at the same time
all right this is it this is the cut I
needed to have the camera more angles Oh
Oh what we learned is that this looks
pretty sweet and slow-motion but the
camera placement could have been way
better show me what you got oh that was
so cool
all those little flecks of paint like
that's so quick and like seeing the Jude
go with the water yeah if you put the
sword over there unless I to frame
suddenly all that chopping action is
going to be in the shot right haven't it
so we have two GoPros one is corridors
one is NICs so here's the blade we have
one GoPro here looking down the blade
and then we take the second GoPro and
put it straight up horizontal along the
blade and this one will see all the
debris that lies out any other GoPro
will see the cut and then what if we can
somehow stitch those shots together for
a super wide shot that is a little high
level I don't know if I can do that oh
that would be cool though
we might have a bit at a stitch mark but
that looks I mean it's just janky
embrace' jank as it is listen I came in
today to find that Nick and Ren hadn't
gotten the footage that they were
looking for yesterday and apparently
they've been working on this video now
for two or three days this is the last
day to get the footage that they need to
get in order to make this video cool for
scrap in this whole project I'm trying
to line these up so that I have the
right 25% of this camera matching up
with the left 25% of this other camera
so that I could have them overlapping
any chance ready
[Music]
hey Nick not bad I think that turned out
well one maybe two more and then we go
check the footage oh man and weird stuff
in the distance lines up really nicely
but stuff right next to the cameras they
don't match up quite as much so the way
we fix it is by trying to get the lenses
as close to each other is physically
popped like this so I'm just going to
create a couple like super super small
wood things help support now I made a
bit of a wedge not perfect or anything
but hopefully it'll get the job done
very very dump thing I'm about to do hey
hey Carmichael
you're right in time for the dumb thing
alright then I am hot gluing this piece
of wood to the bill pearl alright so
here is the final alignment at this
point we just got to get this thing
going we're going to be losing light red
we have 15 minutes this year here come
in sorry Nick Rankin melt dude freaking
out okay
we're running out of time don't run with
the filler drip
no record video right there both rolling
now I am NOT a samurai this is not ideal
well we have now officially chopped
everything we have this is our little
15-minute GoPro rig we are just in time
we're about to lose light so hopefully
we still have enough so that the
background is a motion blurred so we got
what we got if it doesn't work it
doesn't work that is what it is let's go
look at the footage these guys have been
rolling on swords cutting through like
fruit for about a week now and we're
going to finally get to see the footage
I'm super excited okay so this is the
first rig where it's just the regular
mounts of cameras drill oh that's right
did you spin all the way around and hit
it a second time those are hooks that's
up creep that's really cool that's cool
it's oddly reminds me of VR game this is
essentially a thousand frames a second
your voice oh I'm gonna make it through
oh no no I have to go too fast all those
floors it was like it didn't make us
zeros like though
so the second rig was a super janky one
but it still works check it out so here
is it without any blending the two
frames lined up and the sword actually
spent a whole lot of that shot what
isn't like just like the like modern
like Sheila's oh yeah there we go
that is it was somehow into the beam one
of the coolest things of us so here's
the blended shower in like the repeat
edges stuff and like a feather mask I
kind of try to go somewhere close yeah a
little I think you'd gnarly there a
little bit
oh no what happened is that you got to
select the news wanting to go up while I
was still pulling it it was too dark
that was the issue Ren Nick that's are
not really good that would be the
ultimate fatality shock skies and you're
not fired
[Music]
[Applause]
what No